[Music]
on this sunday night from london the
perfect end to a once-in-a-lifetime
celebration
[Music]
the pageant outside the palace and the
roars from the crowd
as the queen says she's touched by the
outpouring of affection
the humor perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich and
even a hologram of her majesty
plus reflections on her 70-year reign
somber anniversary in ontario i now have
a gaping wound left in my heart honoring
the osvald family murdered because of
their faith
and the crises the world is neglecting
all of them on one continent
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from london
it was a pageant fit for a queen ten
thousand people from essential workers
to celebrities making their way to
buckingham palace all here to pay
tribute to the woman who was reigned for
seven decades
and inside the same gold state carriage
used at her coronation the queen not in
person but a hologram of the young queen
waving to the crowd as she has for 70
years
good evening from london on this final
day of the queen's platinum jubilee the
four-day celebration marking a moment in
history unlikely to be repeated it
culminated in a spectacular pageant here
in london street parties across the
country and an encore appearance by the
queen on the balcony of buckingham
palace redmond shannon begins our
coverage tonight redmond
donna four days of celebration and
adulation have come to an end a special
long weekend that was seven decades in
the making
a day designed for a queen could hardly
have started in a more british way
charles and camilla tea and cake and
bagpipes in a cricket stadium
and i think he's opening comment twice
because it was only half past 11. it's a
little early
some grey london skies too but in the
capital at least the rain held off of
course not every event can welcome
royalty tens of thousands of street
parties like this one are happening in
communities right across the uk
on the isle of dogs in east london
community groups organized the opening
of an orchard to coincide with the
jubilee i think for most it's an
occasion to get out and be in the
community and chat the jubilee is part
of it many residents in this social
housing project have roots in countries
across the commonwealth ahmed hussein's
family emigrated from bangladesh when he
was four
but because our ancestors worked
directly under the royals that has a
direct influence
and
they speak highly about them but the
next generation there's a split
but there was no split around buckingham
palace thousands lining the mall for the
jubilees grand finale a parade of lavish
pageantry reflecting the queen's
seven-decade reign starring the royals
260 year old gold state coach featuring
a digital projection of the young queen
from her coronation day in 1953
[Music]
the present prince of british pop ed
sheeran poignantly set up the moment
everybody had been waiting for
after two days of rest while the nation
partied a final wave from the queen
herself flanked by the three future
kings charles william and little george
[Music]
[Applause]
visibly slowed by her persistent
mobility problems elizabeth's short
salute sets smiles on faces across the
crowd at 96 royal revelers are
cherishing every appearance had she not
done so it would firstly have underlined
the fact that she was extremely frail
and also there would have been i think a
great deal of disappointment
redmond there were lots of touching
moments today i think my favorite was at
the end when ed sheeran sang is hit
perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the big screen there was a montage of
images of the queen and prince philip
they were married of course for 73 years
he was by her side throughout her reign
and this is the first major event big
milestone since he died it was really
moving
redmond what stood out for you
well don i think for me the highlight
must have been those drones the drone
show at the end of the concert last
night in particular the drones in the
shape of a corgi and a bone but to be
honest overall it wasn't about one thing
it was about the entire weekend it went
off without a glitch it was hugely
impressive and it's it's a big boost for
a country here that often gets down on
itself you know what donna it didn't
even rain over the four days of events
that was until the queen went back
inside today and well look at it now
donna
yeah the rain held off redmond shannon
overlooking tower bridge tonight thanks
more royal coverage coming up now other
news australia has accused the pilot of
a chinese fighter jet of carrying out a
dangerous maneuver near one of its
aircraft in international airspace over
the south china sea it says the chinese
aircraft released flares designed to
interfere with radar systems and came
dangerously close to an australian
surveillance plane
the intercept resulted in a dangerous
maneuver which did pose a safety threat
to the p-8 aircraft and its crew
the australian government has raised our
concerns about the incident with the
chinese government
we are concerned about
this incident
the australian government's revelation
comes just days after the canadian
military accused chinese warplanes of
harassing pilots during a united nations
sanctions mission on north korea sources
have told global news that roughly 60
intercepts between chinese fighter jets
and canadian planes have taken place
since christmas and over two dozen have
been deemed dangerous
back to canada now the city of london
ontario is marking a tragic anniversary
one year ago the ufsalls a muslim family
were hit by a truck while they were out
for an evening walk and what police and
prosecutors say was a hate-motivated
crime only the youngest child survived
he lost his father mother sister and
grandmother abigail beeman looks how the
community is honoring their memory
last year
i would never be able to understand how
all it took was one act of hatred to
change my entire life
a life
where i now have a gaping wound left in
my heart
one year since issa islam lost her 15
year old cousin yamna afzal and maryam
al-sabawi lost her dear friend
the grease is overwhelming
so much so that at times i am no longer
recognizable to those who love me
and at times not even recognizable to
myself
afzal was out for an evening walk with
her parents grandmother and little
brother when a truck jumped the curb and
hit the family killing four of them
there is only one child left 10 years
old which is making all the community
here in isoro
and
and
was still still really still really
upset
police called it a hate motivated crime
the family targeted simply for being
muslim nathaniel veltman is charged with
four murders and one attempted murder
terrorism charges added later his trial
set for the fall of 2023 when i think of
quebec city
and
london a year ago
there are a couple of young men
who will hopefully never again see the
light of day
from inside their prison self
the prime minister among many who spoke
to the crowd in london to kick off a
memorial march just one of multiple
events to remember the family this week
and call for change
do not allow
the progress to be measured only
on the anniversary of our city's darkest
hour
on some annual basis rather
our progress must be measured daily
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done when it comes to combating
islamophobia because uh you know if you
look at it from a practical sense we've
had many meetings many things going on
but
nothing much has happened
on a practical note
teenagers who a year ago were sending
late night texts with their friend and
chatting about harry potter now battling
to end islamophobia my worst nightmare
is having another attack like this
happen
again with so much hate to fight and no
clear path to stop it
abigail beeman global news
ottawa
in british columbia several communities
are on high alert for flooding unusually
cold weather has delayed the spring thaw
but after a weekend of heavy rain and
above average temperatures there are
concerns heavy snow packs could melt
rapidly causing catchments to fill up
and rivers to overflow several cities
from northern bc to the interior are
under local flood watches and high
stream advisories the city of terrace
has put a barrier in place to hold back
the skinai river which is expected to
peak tomorrow
some breaking news from toronto after
days of deliberating a jury has found
singer jacob hogard guilty of sexually
assaulting an ottawa woman causing
bodily harm the former front man for the
canadian band headley has been found not
guilty on two other counts involving
teenage fans hogard had pleaded not
guilty to all three charges he insisted
the encounters
were consensual
ukraine's capital under attack coming up
russian missiles hit kiev plus the
deadly assault on a church in nigeria
we are overlooking the tower of london
on this rainy night we are back in a
moment
at least 49 people have been killed and
hundreds more injured after a massive
fire at a container depot in
southeastern bangladesh it's believed a
fire in a container full of chemicals
triggered an initial blast which then
led to multiple explosions in
surrounding containers people as far
away as four kilometers say they felt
the explosions the number of dead is
expected to rise
after weeks of relative calm several
explosions have once again shaken parts
of ukraine's capital it happened early
this morning
they were russian missiles russia's
defense ministry claims they used
long-range high-precision missiles to
target tanks in kiev supplied by
european countries ukraine though says a
train repair plant was hit and only
grain trucks were damaged at least one
person was injured in an interview with
state media the russian president
vladimir putin warned any western
deliveries of long-range rocket systems
would prompt similar airstrikes the us
germany and the uk have announced plans
to send more weapons to ukraine this
week
we are in london for the queen's
platinum jubilee
corgis are synonymous with her majesty
so it made sense 20 of these corgi
puppets walked in the pageant today she
has had more than 30 corgis and dorgies
during her reign her first and favorite
corgi susan was given to her as a gift
on her 18th birthday
we'll be right back
you're watching global national
[Music]
in nigeria there has been a deadly
attack on a church at least 50 people
were killed when a gunman stormed a
catholic church in the country's
southwest local media reports say the
gunman opened fire before detonating
explosives it happened while people
gathered for mass and many of the
victims are children
nigeria's president and pope francis
have both condemned the attack
there is a clear picture of how many
crises are being ignored by the
international community the norwegian
refugee council a humanitarian
organization released its annual top ten
list of the most neglected crises around
the world and for the first time all 10
are in africa mike armstrong is in the
democratic republic of congo a country
sitting at the top of that grim ranking
they are numbers that boggle the mind
and they're growing in the democratic
republic of the congo a million refugees
have left the country to escape violence
on top of that another 5.5 million
people have been displaced inside the
drc
to make it worse the fighting between
militias and the military is flaring up
again forcing more to leave their homes
every day
[Music]
this woman asks why they can't just stop
so people can tend to their farms and
feed their children
hunger is the other issue about 30
million of the drc's 110 million people
don't have enough to eat that's more
than the entire population of australia
and observers say it's being ignored
if today australia was all the
population was hungry
it would make the headline of all the
medias in the world here 30 million
people are hungry
no one talks about it the norwegian
refugee council puts the crisis in the
democratic republic of the congo at the
top of its list of most neglected crises
in the world
now it's an annual list the group
factors in worldwide media attention
political engagement and funding they
looked at 41 crises around the world and
this year for the first time ever their
entire top ten list was here on this
continent in africa
the differences between the 10 countries
on the shortlist and some other crises
is striking the media attention given to
the situation in ukraine for example
compare it to burkina faso watchers say
about 27 000 english language news
articles were written about its
desperate situation in all of 2021
ukraine gets about 85 000 a day
there are reasons call it whatever you
want like eurocentrism even
racism somewhere these are strong words
but at the end of the day we need to put
the names on it
that difference in attention means a
difference in political engagement the
push to help with funding just isn't
there that's one of the reasons this
list exists to show where global crises
are being ignored the norwegian refugee
council says it's close to halfway
through the year and it's only found
about 10 percent of the money it needs
to help here in the drc whereas when the
call went out for help in the ukrainian
humanitarian crisis it got all the
donations it was after in a single day
mike armstrong global news kinshasa the
democratic republic of the congo
[Music]
the balcke balcony of buckingham palace
is where so many significant royal
moments have been marked over the years
from young elizabeth's first appearance
as a toddler through coronations
weddings and major state occasions
we'll be right back from london
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
for later
how can you do anything but smile at
that the queen didn't make it in person
to all of the events at her platinum
jubilee
but it really didn't matter the huge
crowds were still all there for her
even if you're not a monarchist or you
think the whole thing isn't relevant in
the 21st century there is no denying the
queen has been an enduring even
endearing presence in the world a thread
stretching across seven decades of
history
it feels like she's always been queen
perhaps that's because most people alive
today weren't born when elizabeth began
her reign
she was 25 her life's path was set the
empire was fading she knew the monarchy
had to change with the times
parliamentary institutions with their
free speech and respect for the rights
of minorities
and the inspiration of a broad tolerance
in thought
and its expression
all this we conceive
to be a precious part of our way of life
and outlook
her coronation was the first to be
broadcast on tv and marked the start of
the modernization of the monarchy more
than 20 million people watched it
to stay relevant she needed to be seen
and she's traveled more than any other
monarch this was montreal in 1959
throngs of people greeted her she's made
more trips to canada than any other
country thank you very much and has met
multitudes of people
imagine how many times she's done that
royal wave how many hands she's shaken
you have to soldier on and you have to
put on a brave face and you you
represent all things to all people at
all times robert hardman has written a
biography of the queen which is always
mindful of the fact for the person in
the room it might be just another day at
the office for her but for all the
people around her this is one of the big
days of their life and you mustn't let
them down by this further deliberate
attack on the lives of our king and
queen her resilience shaped during the
nazi bombing campaign of london she
joined the territorial service and
trained as a mechanic she's the only
head of state alive to have worn a
uniform during the second world war
and likely the only monarch who can
strip a gear box in a four-ton truck
she's outlasted countless world leaders
and persevered through fractured family
dynamics in 1992 the year the marriages
of three of her children fell apart she
acknowledged it was an annis horribilis
a horrible year
fast forward 30 years and she's still
here she talks about her belief in sort
of small acts of kindness small steps
that's been her sort of philosophy you
don't need big revamps you know she's
not a brand of soap powder or a
politician where you're suddenly
announcing here's the big thing she
doesn't do big things she does lots and
lots of little things when you've been
doing lots and lots of little things
over 70 years boy does that add up
happy to jubilee man
and thank you
for everything
that's very kind
[Applause]
such a sweet moment that is global
national for this sunday of the platinum
jubilee weekend queen elizabeth has
heard her song what is the national
anthem in this country
sung more times than anyone can count
but at the end of this weekend's
celebrations as she stood on the balcony
with three generations of her family it
was especially poignant the longest
serving monarch in british history heard
god save the queen one more time
sung by tens of thousands of people good
night from london
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you